do you have a favorite jackass for a bit
forever
um obviously anyone that i'm right no
but um
honestly like silence of the lambs was
incredible i think that's the hardest i
ever laughed oh man
just like dave's reactions and pontius
like being like the crazy the music
it's so good and
it's i mean dark shark's so amazing he's
so funny and just seeing his reactions
and situations the fear luck oh yeah um
obviously any bit steve ozin is iconic
and legendary
um
yeah i mean
it was just so fun like i it it's like
being at disneyland as an adult because
when you leave set you're like wow what
was that you know reality sets back in
yeah it's so funny like some of the most
[ __ ] up stuff happened to you and like
you couldn't talk about it and then you
would come here to film a podcast and
we're like oh how was your day today and
you're like that was cool
and then like
then seeing the movie you're like oh
[ __ ] like that's what you were doing
like it's so hard to keep it secret for
years like just act like like just live
my life you know yeah well people kept
people people kept wondering why steve
was looking like the dude from tiger
king jeff with the headband on it yeah
yeah every podcast we did he had the
head the the head
because of the eyebrows yeah yeah i mean
it's just so classic that
in the middle of principle of
photography like what director is like
okay yeah let's rip stevo's eyebrows off
especially when the when the whole idea
was that we were gonna tattoo a penis on
my [ __ ] forehead where the eyebrow
was and you guys never did that
like uh at the very last second
knoxville was like there's too much dick
stuff we're not
that's the one they decide to pull out
from
like no that's i mean i'm still gonna
get a dick tattooed on my forehead but
uh
but yeah it's just it's just crazy that
via that that uh
all right there was no explanation for
why i was the the steve lowe
steve
or jeff lowe that's so funny steve love
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude